Es gibt eine neue Studie zum interstellaren
Objekt Oumuamua.
Woher kommt es und kann es natürlichen Ursprungs
sein oder ist es doch eher eine Aliensonde
oder ein Bruchstück davon.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Die Spekulationen um das interstellare Objekt
oumuamua reissen nicht ab. es ist zu faszinierend
und es birgt zumindest zwei Rätsel: Woher
kommt es und wie konnte es zu uns gelangen?
Und was ist beim Vorbeiflug an der Sonne passiert?
Da hat es nämlich stark beschleunigt und
bis heute gibt es keinen Erklärung.
Abraham Loeb Havard-Professor und Leiter der
Abteilung Astronomie dort hatte die These
aufgestellt, dass es sich um eine Sonde handeln
könnte, von Ausserirdischen gebaut.
Denn so seine Schlussvollgerung: Die Beschleunigung
durch die Sonne ist nur zu erklären, wenn
das Objekt extrem dünn ist, wie ein künstlich
hergestelltes Lichtsegel.
Bei uns im Interview zitierte er Sherlock
Holmes: “Wenn man das Unmögliche ausgeschlossen
hat, muss das, was übrig bleibt, die Wahrheit
sein, so unwahrscheinlich sie auch klingen
mag.”
Denn beim Vorbeiflug wurde nichts beobachtet,
dass auf einen natürlichen Effekt wie eine
Ausgasung schließen lies.
Die jetzt veröffentlichte Studie “The natural
history of ‘Oumuamua” beschäftigt sich
mit der Herkunft des Objektes.
Denn auch hier sah Loeb eine Unwahrscheinlichkeit:
Ein zufälliger Durchflug eines solchen Objektes
ist nur schwer erklärbar, da es nach bisherigen
Annahmen dafür nicht genügend Objekte im
All geben würde.
Ein Astronomieteam hat sich das Objekt jetzt
vorgenommen und alle Eigenschaften akribisch
untersucht.
Das internationale Team veröffentlichte die
Studie am Montag im Fachmagazin “Nature
Astronomy” und vermutet einen natürlichen
Ursprung.
Einer der Astronomen, Matthew Knight von der
University of Maryland, dazu in “Nature
Astronomy”: "Oumuamua ist rötlich und vielen
Objekten, die wir in unserem Sonnensystem
bereits entdeckt haben, ähnlich.
Die Hypothese vom Alienraumschiff ist eine
lustige Idee, aber unsere Analyse legt nahe,
dass es eine ganze Menge natürliche Phänomene
gibt, die das alles erklären können."
Und die Herkunft und Beschleunigung in Richtung
unseres Sonnensystems können zum Beispiel
durch einen Gasplaneten erklärbar sein, der
das rotierende Objekt, das war ja auch eine
der seltsamen Eigenschaften, mit seiner großen
Gravitation aus seinem Sternensystems zu uns
katapultiert hat.
Doch ein Rätsel bleibt weiterhin und so ist
die These von der Aliensonde nicht ganz vom
Tisch.
Was hat die Sonde bei ihrem Vorbeiflug an
der Sonne so stark beschleunigt?
Diese Frage konnte immer noch nicht geklärt
werden.
Es bleibt also spannend.
Ihr wollt einen Clixoom nature Kanal, das
habt ihr in zahlreichen Kommentaren, Nachrichten
auf Telegram und Mails bekundet.
Ihr bekommt ihn.
Denn neben Oumuamua gibt es auch eine dramatische
Meldung zum Thema Klimawandel, die Verpflichtung
zum Klimaschaden.
Moment?
Nationen verpflichten sich dem Klima zu schaden?
Genauso ist es leider.
Darüber mehr hier bei Clixoom nature.
Also unbedingt draufklicken, anschauen und
unbedingt Clixoom nature abonnieren und weitererzählen.
Es ist wichtig um mehr Informationen zum Thema
zu verbreiten.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!